Transcription: Mandy Vincent
Relecteur: eric vautier
Bonsoir.
Lorsque je vois cet enfant,
je me dis qu’il est heureux,
immergé dans cette mer de sable
jusqu’à en avoir plein les oreilles.
Littéralement.
Cette photo était peut-être prémonitoire
puisque tout a commencé par un rêve.
A l’âge de cinq ans,
je voyais des athlètes voler à la télé
et j’avais envie de faire la même chose,
de pouvoir m’extraire de cette terre
et de la gravité quelques secondes.
Même si l’idée d’explorer
a toujours été présente,
ce rêve ne m’a jamais réellement quitté.
Aujourd’hui, je suis athlète.
J’ai le privilège de vivre de ma passion
depuis plus de quinze ans maintenant.
J’ai remporté des titres mondiaux,
des titres paralympiques
et je suis recordman du monde
dans ma catégorie.
(Applaudissements)
C’est gentil, je n’en attendais pas tant.
Je suis né avec
différentes caractéristiques,
dont trois que l’on nomme handicaps.
Je suis asthmatique chronique,
j’ai un trouble déficitaire de l’attention
avec hyperactivité et impulsivité
et je suis née avec une agénésie
de l’avant-bras gauche,
ce qu’on appelle
une malformation congénitale.
Deux handicaps invisibles
et un handicap visible.
D’ailleurs, saviez-vous qu’il y a 80%
des handicaps qui sont invisibles
et seulement 20% qui sont visibles ?
Il y a environ 12 millions de personnes
qui vivent avec un handicap en France
avec différentes typologies de handicap.
Handicap physique, mental,
sensoriel, cognitif, psychique,
maladie invalidante.
Ces handicaps font partie de moi
mais à aucun moment ces caractéristiques,
au même titre qu’être métis
et chausser du 47 et demi,
ne sont mon identité
et ne peuvent me définir.
Comme aucune de vos différences,
aucune de vos caractéristiques
n’est votre identité également.
Chaque handicap vient avec son lot
d’avantages et d’inconvénients.
Pendant toute ma scolarité,
j’ai pu faire du piano
au lieu de la flûte,
pour le plus grand bonheur de ma mère
et de mes oreilles également.
J’ai été souvent en retard mais pour
une raison qui est difficile à partager,
c’est que je ne trouvais plus mon bras,
ma prothèse,
avant de pouvoir partir à l’école.
Ça m’arrive encore aujourd’hui.
C’est la première fois
que je partage ça, avec vous.
Mon enfance fut assez joyeuse.
J’étais un enfant énergique,
rêveur, sportif, curieux
et passionné de ce qu’il découvrait.
L'adolescence fut un peu plus compliquée.
J’ai vécu du harcèlement à l’école.
Du gamin qui fascinait tout le monde
parce qu’il avait une prothèse bionique
avec un poignet qui pouvait
tourner en illimité,
je suis passé du jour
au lendemain au manchot,
à celui qu’on montrait du doigt,
à qui on prenait ses affaires, son manteau
et qu’on mettait à la poubelle.
Ça a duré quelques semaines,
quelques mois même,
jusqu’à ce qu’un matin, je sois paralysé
au fond de mon lit, en pleurs,
et que je dise :
« Je ne peux plus y aller. »
J’ai changé d’établissement.
Mais ce qui m’a réellement
permis de rebondir
et de vivre cette période compliquée,
ça a été bien évidemment le soutien
de ma mère et de ma famille,
mais également deux piliers essentiels.
L’éducation,
celle de mes parents et de l’école.
Le sport et la culture,
la musique étant également
une de mes autres passions.
Le handicap est défini
aujourd’hui en partie
par une problématique
ou des problématiques
que vous pouvez rencontrer
face à un environnement.
C’est réellement le contexte
qui crée la situation de handicap.
Par exemple, pour moi,
vous êtes tous et toutes
en situation de handicap.
Si, maintenant,
on va sur un sautoir en longueur,
je vous assure que vous êtes tous
et toutes en situation de handicap.
Si une femme avec sa poussette
et un homme en fauteuil
sont en bas d’un escalier
et qu’il n’y a pas d’ascenseur,
ils sont tous les deux
en situation de handicap.
Handicap ou non, il est essentiel
de pouvoir être concentré sur l’humain
et de pouvoir apporter, si besoin est,
un accompagnement
et la résolution de problématiques.
Aujourd’hui, je me prépare
pour mes sixièmes Jeux paralympiques,
pour Paris 2024.
Et ce n’est pas réellement
le rêve d’enfant qui m’anime
ou le fait de gagner des médailles,
même si j’ai envie de réussir.
C’est surtout le fait de pouvoir
changer le regard sur le handicap,
changer le regard sur la différence
parce que les discriminations
sont réelles et importantes.
Une des parties du métier d’athlète,
ce n’est pas seulement de s’entraîner,
de faire des compétitions,
c’est également de répondre
à des interviews.
Et parfois, il y a des moments qui sont
un petit peu plus cocasses que d’autres.
Lorsque j’étais au début de ma carrière,
un journaliste est venu me voir
et m’a dit : « Mais pourquoi
le traitement médiatique sur le handicap
n’a pas une image si positive
que ça en France ?
- Écoutez, ce serait plutôt à moi
de vous poser cette question.
Moi, je suis plutôt spécialiste
de châteaux de sable
plutôt que spécialiste du handicap.
Mais je pense que les choses évoluent
et que des événements comme
les Jeux paralympiques participent
à humaniser le handicap,
à humaniser la différence.
Car derrière chaque personne,
il y a une personnalité
et on ne peut pas la cacher
derrière une étiquette. »
Humaniser la différence.
Ce sera donc ça, ma mission.
Si je parle d’humaniser le handicap,
c’est que je sous-entends
que des personnes en situation
de handicap seraient déshumanisées.
Je me suis alors interrogé sur le sujet
et j’ai découvert les travaux
d’Albert Bandura,
un psychologue social,
un des plus influents du XXᵉ siècle,
et il a travaillé pendant un peu plus
de 30 ans sur le désengagement moral.
Il définit le désengagement moral
comme un processus d’étapes
pouvant conduire à la déshumanisation.
Ce qui signifie, pouvant conduire
à enlever tout caractère humain,
toute générosité à un individu
ou à un groupe de personnes.
Je vais citer quelques-unes de ces étapes.
Vous avez la justification morale.
« De toute façon, ce sont des incapables.
Ne t’inquiète pas, ils ne comprennent pas.
Tu peux leur faire ce que tu veux. »
La comparaison avantageuse.
« Venez rencontrer les super-humains. »
Meet the superhumans.
C’était la campagne pour
les Jeux paralympiques de 2012.
Super campagne,
assez flatteuse pour les athlètes.
Sauf que réellement à l’opposé radical
de ce que peuvent vivre
des personnes en situation de handicap
en Angleterre et au Royaume-Uni.
Vous avez le mépris par les insultes,
par le regard, par les moqueries.
« Sale manchot, espèce d’handicapé,
tu ne serais pas autiste, toi ? »
Et vous avez la déshumanisation
et il n’y a pas besoin d’aller très loin.
Vous avez simplement
besoin d’ouvrir le journal
et de lire les titres des faits divers.
« Violente agression à Paris,
un handicapé décède. »
Jean-Christophe Parisot,
qui est le premier préfet
en situation de handicap en France,
en 2012,
a donné une interview
en 2006 où il disait :
« Le handicap,
véritable baromètre d’humanisation,
nous indique que la solidarité recule. »
Malheureusement,
Jean-Christophe avait raison
car pour la cinquième année consécutive,
le handicap est le premier critère
de discrimination en France.
Le constat est assez dur.
J’ai un peu l’impression
d’avoir avalé la pilule rouge
et de ne pas me réveiller
au pays des merveilles
mais dans une dure réalité.
Et surtout d’autres millions de personnes
sont également déshumanisées
sous d’autres étiquettes.
C’est dangereux
pour notre démocratie et nos libertés.
Et ça peut être assez catastrophique
puisque ça peut mener à des exclusions,
à de la violence, à du terrorisme,
voire à des génocides.
J’ai continué à regarder
ce que disait Albert car je me suis dit :
« Ok mais c’est quoi les solutions ?
Comment on peut se réengager moralement ?»
Et là, Albert nous indique deux voies.
La première, c’est l’inhibition,
inhiber nos caractères inhumains
ou pouvant être inhumains.
Il y a plutôt les hôpitaux
ou les prisons pour ça.
Et la deuxième, c’est la pro-action.
Et je ne sais pas vous
mais, moi, je choisis la pro-action.
Il y a deux leviers centraux qui sont
mes deux piliers depuis mon enfance.
C’est l’éducation
que je lie avec la pédagogie.
Il est plus facile de construire
des fondations solides
que de déconstruire
pour construire de nouveau.
Et le sport et la culture car ce sont
de magnifiques moyens d’expression,
des langages qui nous permettent
de créer du lien social
mais également de passer des messages
et de travailler sur des valeurs.
En 2021, vous avez eu une campagne,
#WeThe15.
C’était lors de la cérémonie d’ouverture
des Jeux paralympiques à Tokyo.
Et c’est la plus grande campagne
mondiale pour les droits humains.
#WeThe15, « Nous, les 15 »,
ça représente les 15% des personnes
en situation de handicap dans le monde.
Ça représente un peu plus
de 1,2 milliard de personnes.
Ce que j’ai aimé dans cette campagne,
je vous invite à la regarder,
c’est qu’on va banaliser des choses
classiques de la vie quotidienne,
que l’on vit lorsqu’on est
adolescent ou adulte.
Et justement, le but, c'était d'humaniser.
On n’est ni au-dessus, ni en-dessous,
juste banal comme n’importe
quel être humain qui se respecte.
Vous pouvez également
travailler sur le regard
par un lien avec la culture, avec l’art,
la création pour changer la perception
sur une prothèse par exemple,
un bras qui peut être manquant.
J’ai lancé pour la 2e fois l’an dernier
un concours « Golden Arm Trophy »,
où le grand public pouvait
dessiner la prothèse
que je vais porter pour les compétitions.
Là, c’est Raphaël, quatorze ans,
qui a remporté le concours
et on avait fait un événement
lors du World Cleanup Day
où Maylis, la body-painteuse, avait
dessiné sur le bras de ces enfants.
Et donc, eux et moi, on avait
tous un bras coloré et original
et on était égaux.
On avait travaillé également
avec un designer, Dimitry Hlinka,
qui a fait cette magnifique
prothèse sculpturale.
Première fois qu’il travaillait
dans le domaine du handicap
mais pour moi, c’est un projet de vie
et Théo Saffroy est le photographe.
Je me suis rendu compte au fur et à mesure
que ces créations sont
des outils d’ouverture au dialogue.
Le plus important,
c’est lorsque je vais dans les écoles,
on travaille avec des associations auprès
des enfants pour casser les stéréotypes,
les idées reçues,
que nous, les adultes
ou la société avons pu transférer.
Et ça prend 30 secondes
pour les déconstruire.
Cette photo est réellement historique.
Ça se passait le 8 octobre 2022
et c’était lors de la première journée
paralympique de l’histoire.
On a Markus Rehm qui est dans
les airs avec ce magnifique saut
et qui porte une lame qui est propulsive.
Il y a eu des milliers de personnes.
C’était une ambiance vraiment incroyable.
Ils ont rencontré un peu plus de 160
athlètes olympiques et paralympiques,
ensuite s’essayer à des sports
paralympiques également.
Et surtout, ce qui était incroyable,
quelles que soient vos différences,
votre couleur de peau, votre origine,
votre orientation sexuelle, votre genre,
votre handicap ou non,
on vivait cette journée pleinement
et on partageait des émotions ensemble.
Le rôle de Marcus et le rôle
des athlètes paralympiques est essentiel
parce que justement il est inspirant.
Il peut également permettre
aux personnes de s’identifier.
Handicap ou non.
Et il sensibilise également
sur le handicap,
soit par simple explication
ou parce que vous allez essayer le sport
et vous allez vous mettre en situation.
Regardez le regard de ces enfants.
Regardez le regard de ces gens ce jour-là.
Je peux vous assurer qu’ils ne vont
jamais oublier cette journée.
Les plus proches se sont pris du sable,
donc, ils vont encore moins oublier.
Ça restera gravé dans leur mémoire,
comme pour mes nièces qui étaient là.
Ce jour-là, j’ai ressenti la même chose
que lors des Jeux paralympiques
de Londres en 2012.
Énormément de fraternité et d’égalité.
Pour la première fois de l’histoire,
vous allez dire : « C’est beaucoup »,
en effet, première fois de l’histoire
où il y eu plus d’affluence
pour les Jeux paralympiques
que pour les Jeux olympiques
en spectateurs.
Je sautais un 10 septembre, à 10h du matin
et il y avait 80 000 personnes
dans le stade, pas une place vide.
Les Anglais ont fait un travail incroyable
d'organisation avec les médias
et de pédagogie également.
C’est sûr, ils ont réussi à gagner,
peut-être dix ou vingt ans sur le regard,
sur les changements de la perception
par rapport au handicap.
Le problème, aujourd’hui,
lorsque vous êtes en situation de handicap
au Royaume-Uni, vous vivez moins bien
qu’avant les Jeux paralympiques en 2012.
Ça veut dire qu’il y a besoin de pouvoir
collaborer avec des institutions,
puisque c’est un événement
qui est simplement une opportunité.
Nous, les athlètes,
on n’a pas envie qu’il se passe ça
pour les Jeux paralympiques de Paris 2024.
On va avoir la chance d’accueillir
les Jeux olympiques
et les Jeux paralympiques en 2024.
Et pour la première fois
également dans l’histoire,
il y aura un comité d’organisation
dont le rôle sera de pouvoir livrer
des jeux spectaculaires
incroyables, ce qui sera le cas,
et j’espère que vous serez de la fête.
Mais ce sera aussi de pouvoir travailler
pour laisser un héritage positif
à la population
et que des millions de personnes
puissent en bénéficier.
C’est pouvoir travailler
sur des clubs paraccueillants,
3000 clubs paraccueillants
vont être formés,
que des personnes qui vivent dans
les milieux ruraux ou dans les quartiers
puissent accéder plus facilement au sport
et qu’il y ait des femmes
qui soient formées,
plus de femmes dans
les institutions dirigeantes.
Et d’autres causes sociétales
et également environnementales,
en proposant des modèles plus durables.
Mais ce qui est très important,
c’est qu’on y arrivera seulement
si on est tous ensemble.
Donc, on a besoin de vous.
On a besoin du public, des médias,
des institutions, des entreprises
pour que réellement on puisse
laisser un héritage positif
pour des millions de personnes
qui vont tous et toutes nous bénéficier.
Si je pouvais résumer mon propos
et tout ce que j’ai pu vous dire,
ce serait autour de la générosité.
Les philosophes
et la science nous enseignent
que la gratitude et la générosité
sont deux clés du bonheur.
Mais je pense que la générosité,
c’est aussi un garant de notre humanité.
Soyez généreux envers vous-même,
soyez généreux dans vos engagements,
soyez généreux
avec vos proches, votre famille
et soyez généreux avec les autres.
« Bien loin de m’appauvrir,
ta différence m’enrichit. »
Saint-Exupéry.
Je vous remercie.
(Applaudissements)